[Music]  you can't solve  everything with money but you can't him  you haven't changed at all  excuse me what the frittata  i'm in the family business and now you  work for me boomers  let's roll is that me baby corp needs  you to drink this formula for one last  mission  you want me to be a baby again  i'm texting him  give me that block of seagulls  the boss is back baby i work alone or at  least  not with him we need to work together to  save the family business  we're going to have to face evil babies  creepy babies  don't look at me jail your babies  and ninja babies  is this some kind of a ninja boy band  huh oh my gosh oh my gosh  thank you navigation we did it i guess  we did i was talking about me and  precious oh  oh gross  [Music]  bye